jacques anne sophie favier
[Musique]
comment font chier quand on est enrhumé
attraperait avec si vous n'êtes pas de
là avec votre veste non non moi je suis
pour le papier jetables ses propres jeux
ni ses profits génie que je tiens à l'en
timsit fait mouche à table servez vous
moi je suis bon moi je suis c'est mon
but des vcub fait le malin il ya quand
même des gestes à rentrer évidemment on
évite de regarder ce qu'on a rejeté tout
le monde en a parlé à retrouver sophie
favier à paris en plein shopping
accompagnée d'une amie conseillère en
look l'animatrice de télévision se rend
dans sa boutique de prédilection la
haute direction des parités mais vous
allez vas y fonce saisissante à c'est
une bible ouverte
la légende vivante elle parle de la mode
d'une manière on dirait du baudelaire
aux pressions françaises perdent
christian et claudie christian et
claudie connaissent très bien sophie
elle s'habille chez eux depuis des
années elle a évolué c'est vrai que dans
les années 80 c'était plus bling bling
et tout ça et là on sent très bien une
démarche de minimalisme et de modernité
sophie favier tient à rester au goût du
jour et cathy s'avère être un soutien
psychologique précieux dans le thème un
peu de nous là d'abord elle effraie
simple à cette cérémonie par fermente
toujours souriante et je pense que ça
c'est très important à rome
changement de programme pour sophie qui
se fait maintenant plus studieuse elle a
rendez-vous avec dominique boucher chef
de renom qui a officié à la tour
d'argent et au crillon pour un cours de
cuisine un petit coup c'est pour faire
peur à plat et la leçon du jour sera le
sable et aux figues d'un poids santé
reprendre ma place à la fougue et pétrir
ça va être assez durs cd man master moi
j'ai des mânes camionneurs bien malaxer
bien tel est le coup de patte
non mais j'aime j'aime la bonne chère
donc ça ils sont bien que le mcr skis
merveilleux voilà fonds d'aidé couteau
qui coule comme ça vous m'avez appris ça
me fait de la peine de le manger voyez
après quelques heures de cuisine
sophie elle même semble surprise par le
résultat bien au-delà de ses espérances
pour le déjeuner sophie retrouve un ami
écrivain eric cazalot biographe de
sylvie vartan il vient de publier son
premier roman une nouvelle aventure
soutenu par sophie favier
c'est une surprise avant parce que mon
oeil droit effectivement première
à dix mille fois on parle il faut que
j'en parle l'a voulu qu'on fasse un un
vidéoclip y en a qui font de frein
internet je pense
voilà et là on n'a pas pu a pas mal de
gens d'ailleurs c'est quand on sera
premier rang c'était très difficile donc
avoir le soutien de quelqu'un de connu
forcément c'est nul c'est comme un petit
frère
il est intéressant parce qu'il me fait
écrire
il photographie il aime mettre les
autres en lumière les généreux mais il a
un petit côté calimero que j'adore on
dirait qu'il est triste moralité pas du
tout
qui est
et en ce qui concerne sa carrière ses
projets et ses contrats l'animatrice
remets tout entre les mains d'une
personne de confiance son avocat et à
partir de là ça rigole plus chapeau
comme chez moi ici
voilà j'ai ensuite on appelle ça va être
intéressant
c'est un jeu qui le temps je me disais
sur internet un jour je m'apprêtais tout
le monde ton image il n'y aura pas deux
campagnes d'affichage ce sera simplement
visible sur le net
voilà je finirai presque les yeux fermés
non mais c'est ce qui me correspond plus
qui me connaît très bien donc on avance
plus vite c'est une heure une valeur
sûre sophie pourrait donc prêté son
visage pour un site de jeux en ligne
mais aujourd'hui ce sont ses mains
qu'elle met à contribution pour une
association de lutte contre le sida
concrètement on va faire comme quand on
était à l'école on va faire le contour
des mois passés c'est rigolo alors une
après une après l'autre et le tee shirt
avec le contour des mains de sophie sera
vendu sur le site internet de
l'association
c'est vous qui décrivait ah oui tous
chinois
je suis en vie libre et décontractée
l'égérie de la télé des années 90 et
devenues une marraine de coeur sincères
et chaleureuses
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
sophie favier
bienvenue sur plateau témoins parlaient
se fit alors vous êtes né le 5 octobre
1963 à lyon exactement sur le plateau de
la croix rousse
quand vous avez cinq ans votre famille
déménage dans une belle propriété a créé
piola pape vous appelez le château oui
parce qu'il y avait deux tours donc
c'était mon château là vous avez vécu
une enfance très heureuse là bas
entourée d'animaux avec des parents très
aisément amer architecte un peu fou fou
de mes gentils et puis une maman dans la
coiffure artiste passionné l'un de
l'autre
avec tout ce que ça peut comporter la
fougue amoureuse des éclats de voix
voilà mais plein de bonheur vous avez 15
ans qu'on votre père s'en va oui hélas
vous déménagez évidemment on quitte et
on quitte le château pour plus petits là
c'est un double choc à caluire oui vous
savez des choses dit qu il ya
caluire-et-cuire oui alors votre maman
effectivement dolores tenait des salons
de coiffure à lyon et vous êtes très
jeune baigné dans le milieu de la beauté
j'étais quand qu'être très vite et très
tôt et est passionnée par je coiffais
mes poupées des méchas j'ai eu un singe
aussi j'ai vraiment c'était le grand
bonheur mais après le bac vous vous
inscrivez en fac de droit pour être
avocate
oui enfin je m'inscris mais il m'arrive
une belle aventure ces rencontres là le
destin va frapper à votre porte en la
personne de catherine corbineau bras
droit de stéphane collaro que vous avez
rencontrés l'été précédent lors de
vacances en famille à saint tropez et
elle organise le casting des coco girl
ce qui était complètement fou ce que je
suis arrivé il y avait des beauté
sublime suédoise magnifique défi d'un
mètre quatre-vingts jeunes évidemment je
ne correspondent à aucun de ces critères
et puis c'est au moment de me filmer
me faire parler je les ai beaucoup amusé
que mon sésame ans et voilà ils n'ont
retenu que ça et puis il avait déjà
sélectionné quatre jeunes femmes et
corinne charby qui était chanteuse
en fait c'est des folies d'arrivée du
groupe à la dernière minute et ils m'ont
donc appelé si je puis dire à la
rescousse et ça fait mon bonheur voilà
laventure comment si en fait au départ
vous envisagez ça comme un comme un
petit job ou pensez pas en faire votre
carrière
c'est du mans c'est vraiment le métier
qui est venue vers vous mais je n'avais
aucune envie d'être ni chanteuse
danseuse encore un mannequin et
comédienne
non non je voulais vraiment être
maîtresse d'école vétérinaire mais je
déteste elle s'en est surtout avocat
j'aurais adoré être avocate laura 18 ans
donc voilà danseuse donc aux cowboys
votre physique effectivement appétissant
votre petit cheveu sur la langue ça fait
craquer tout le monde et ça va durer
trois ans il l'a vous partez sur canal+
animer un jeu qui s'appelle max hit est
alors on a beaucoup discuté pour savoir
si vous étiez vraiment partie mais c'est
collaro qui vous avez viré parce que
vous aviez fait des émules dans newlook
en fait non j'avais fait ces photos bien
avant juste je me rappelle puisque maman
avait signé une lettre parce que je
n'étais pas tout à fait majeure est en
fait c'était un job c'était pour me
marrer et puis évidemment quand je suis
arrivé à la télévision ma célébrité et
envoie la lecture sorte il est sorti
voilà voilà
mais c'est pour ça qu'il vous a viré si
vous voulez les autres filles vous savez
les filles entre elles font pas toujours
gentil avant dit mais pourquoi elle a
fait ça ça ça ternit un peu l'image des
coco girl
après ils ont posé pour d'autres
magasins jean phi phi que pendant que
vous êtes très flatté qu alain de greef
vous appelle en fait
ah oui mais c'est à dire que de femmes
troncs je deviens non feinte jeu il ya
mon nom qui est écrit en bas donc je me
dis on me fait confiance en me faire
parler enfin c'est c'est eh oui c'était
un peu plus puis canal c'est l aventure
aux fiches dit très flatté d'être auprès
de ppda
luche de lys blancs ouais donc c'était
merveilleux c'était il y avait marc
toesca pour le top 50
on était en clair pour moi c'était une
super promo alors vous avez aussi tenter
une carrière dans le cinéma à ce moment
là non j'ai été approché plusieurs fois
et notamment pour le casting de joyeuses
pâques
et puis ils ont préféré sophie marceau
ils ont bien fait vous avez joué dans
pas où tu es entré on t'a pas vu sortir
oui enfin c'est parce que j'aimerais
jouer c'est vraiment voilà la figuration
alors on fait des tentatives dans la
chanson aussi il ya un morceau dont on
se souvient c'est il me tape sur les
nerfs et que l'adaptation d'un tube
brésilien très connu oui vous faites
comme tout casser pour moi mais j'adore
en fait ce qui m'a plu dans ce métier
c'est finalement je n'étais pas
programmé pour le faire donc j'étais si
vous voulez à la fois boulimie qu puis
après avec le temps face à lyon devient
épicurien alors après deux ans de canal
dechavanne vous donne une chance énorme
avec ciel mon mardi et coucou c'est nous
oui oui il me dit j'adore un petit
cheveu sur la langue
venez me voir au bureau et voilà et
m'accueillit très gentiment et renault
rares les quittait pour pour pour voler
de ses propres ailes il y avait une
place à prendre si je puis dire donc il
m'a pas fait de cadeau à je vous le dis
tout de suite m'a dit tu freines une
émission et puis j'en ai fait je suis
resté quatre ans avec lui on se souvient
d'un jour il y avait un vrai commerce
qui jouait de la guitare
vous dansez sur la table c'est énorme
oui ce qui m'a valu la grande sympathie
de toute la communauté juive parce que
tout le monde était persuadé que j'ai
peut-être confession juive et parce que
je danse assez bien la danse orientale
en savez comme j'aime le couscous et
comme j'aime la paella donc c'était
c'était peu que vous avez été de votre
surnom sophie favier et après il ya eu
le saviez vous donc là vous êtes une
star de la télé à l'époque de deux chats
vaches une grosse vedette voilà comment
réagit votre entourage
mais mieux du monde commence et que
c'est que les médias
je pense avoir toujours un bon rapport
si juste peut-être au moment où où
j'attendais ma fille
ouh là ça a été un petit peu la
bousculade donc j'ai choisi d'en parler
enfin de prendre un rendez vous avec les
médias ce qui m'a valu la couverture de
paris match dont je suis très fier parce
que je suis une petite personne et il
fait la couv de match et pas mal
vous avez de l'argent à cette époque oui
convenablement
oui j'en ai mis de côté oui je me suis
acheté un appartement
voila voila je vis dans mon appartement
de jeunes filles c'est bien mais je ne
suis pas quelqu'un d'immense et mme
henry et l'amour alors ça vous a apporté
des rencontres amoureuses cette
célébrité
alors c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
la célébrité isole la célébrité vous
apporte la jalousie dans votre vie
l'envi alors vous la prenez comme
voulait elle peut être positive et très
négative très néfaste moi j'en ai j'en
ai quand même beaucoup souffert mais
j'avais toujours saucisse est cette
réserve en moi de cette espèce de petite
voix qui vivait protège toi
ouais encore que j'ai fait et j'ai quand
même fait des choses très déculottée ce
qui prouve que je suis assez courageux
finalement et que que jose des choses
mais j'ai pas manqué d'amour si ça peut
répondre à votre question quel a été le
meilleur moment de cette époque
dechavanne visons le succès mais
collégiale enfin je n'ai jamais dit que
j'étais une méga star et que j'étais la
plus belle est la meilleure je me suis
toujours beaucoup méfier de tous ces
compliments facile quel a été le pire
moment de cette époque l isolement
la mauvaise solitude celle qui est
subite et pas et pas choisi et des
moments où ça marche moins bien aussi
ensuite ça va moins bien parce que vous
faites une émission qui s'appelle sophie
sens interdit qu'un carton d'audience
oui c'était pas mal et que votre
producteur christophe dechavanne juge
graveleuses il ne tombait en quelque
sorte ça j'en ai beaucoup voulu
il laisse tomber mais il y avait aussi
une grande concurrente c'était amanda
lear pour méfiez-vous des blondes et je
pense qu'elle est une blonde de trop et
c'était moi voilà vous a déçu ça
beaucoup beaucoup parce que j'ai pas su
alors là pour le coup je n'étais pas
armé et j'ai pleuré comme une gamine
dans mon coin et je me rappelle pascale
breugnot c'est la seule qui m'a appelé
qui m'a dit fu chi faut que tu te
remonte et ben je pense que j'ai pas su
j'ai pas su le faire parce que là ils
meurent et fallu un producteur et
j'ai fait ça la fierté d'espagnols qui
m'habitait et je peux ça ferait
maintenant je ne gérais totalement
différemment mais j'aurais dû reprendre
mon téléphone il m'expliqua et
christophe
en tout cas les à l'époque aller voir un
tiède bougeotte qui je pense mais bien
pour le coup mais non je me suis braquée
voilà j'avais été reçus par monsieur le
lait à l'époque était le big boss et
puis bon je pense qu'ils me prenait pour
une petite comme quoi tout simplement je
me rappelle d'une anecdote qui est
terrible je n'ai jamais raconté je vais
vous la raconter j'ai tourné la veille
de mon anniversaire et mon mon mari de
le père de ma fille vivait à saint
martin donc à huit kilomètres de paris
ils ont fait venir ce qui était en soi
un très très très beau cadeau et j'avais
et derrière dans les coulisses paraît-il
je dis bien paraît-il un énorme gâteau
d'anniversaire que je n'ai jamais vu
parce qu'il paraît que j'étais très
mauvaise sauf que au moment de la
diffusion d'émissions j'ai fait plus de
54 % de parts de marché en deuxième
partie de soirée ce qui est un énorme
carton et je n'ai même pas été payés
pour l'émission pour l'avoir animée
c'est vrai qu'elle est elle était page
elle était perçue ici on a réussi
c'était une première donc latefa nous
avait quand même donné une date d'une
deuxième émission et christophe n'a pas
voulu à produire alors pour quelle
raison je ne sais pas ce qu'ils ont été
piqués peut-être surpris du succès je ne
sais pas en tout cas j'avais rien
demandé un jour il m'a appelé en son
bureau en me disant je vais te faire de
toi une star il l'a fait mais mais comme
ça fait dur ensuite vous passez à sacrée
soirée et jean pierre foucault super mec
avec sébastien joly va il faut que je
bouge je vois là donc oui l'euro
millions oui voilà oui après après
c'était différentes autres choses
difficiles après fait des apparitions
est serré comme sous le soleil oui il
faut des livres du théâtre enfin ça va
quoi vous n'êtes pas à la rue ensuite
nous ça n'a plus la note est la même que
l'élève la même brillant et même couleur
et la gloire évidemment aujourd'hui vous
êtes nostalgique de l'époque de cheval
quand je l'appelle il me répond pas j'ai
fait un peu crétin il me problème au
téléphone je trouve ça un peu vachard
parce que je pense que les prescriptions
maintenant oui voilà on pourrait
peut-être prendre le temps d'un verre
finalement j'ai trahi et 80 et plus je
le connais pas
mais pris un verre ensemble on sait
jamais parlé il ne sait même pas qui je
suis et ça c'est je trouve ça mais enfin
des rapports humains pitoyable on peut
pas être comme ça alors bon c'est vrai
que pour lui tout va bien mais je trouve
qu'il a aussi connu le creux de la vague
et à un moment donné humainement il faut
apprendre les quelque chose et j'ai
l'impression que ces gens là
n'apprennent pas alors si c'était à
refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez
pas pareil justement cette grande
déception vous referiez de la télé mais
le jour où vous faites
sophie sens interdit à ce moment là vous
vous battez voilà c'est ça je me serais
battu et grands aujourd'hui je me bats
comme à lyon parce que je pense que
j'étais j'étais vraiment sur les rails
pour faire une très jolie carrière ça
j'en reste persuadé
alors le jour vous allez mourir spams
avec qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
écrive sur leurs tombes
soyez sages mais pas trop ah ah c'est
bien c'est très heureux de rallumer la
lumière sur oust merci maman merci les
corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus